veamos cómo podemos encontrar el
resultado de cuatro enteros y un cuarto
menos dos enteros y dos cuartos pausa el
vídeo e intenta conseguirlo antes de que
trabajemos juntos
muy bien lo primero que puedes intentar
hacer es reescribir esto como cuatro y
un cuarto menos dos y dos cuartos la
razón del por qué es útil escribirlo de
esta manera es que podemos decir mira
cada uno de estos números mixtos tiene
una parte entera y una parte
fraccionaria así que primero intentemos
restar las partes fraccionarias y
después restar las partes enteras y eso
a menudo funcionará pero cuando vayamos
a esta parte fraccionaria y nos
preguntemos cómo restar dos cuartos de
un cuarto ya que dos cuartos es más
grande que un cuarto puede que de manera
inmediata nos encontremos en un problema
entonces cómo lo resolvemos
bueno la noción de reagrupar viene al
rescate no sólo vamos a restar dos
cuartos de un cuarto estamos restando
dos y dos cuartos de cuatro y un cuarto
por lo tanto podemos tomar un poco del
valor de cuatro y reagrupar lo en la
parte fraccionaria a qué nos referimos
bueno vamos a ver al cuatro como tres
más cuatro cuartos por otra parte
tendremos que cuatro cuartos más un
cuarto es lo mismo que cinco cuartos y
entonces podemos reescribir esto como
tres enteros y cinco cuartos menos dos
enteros y dos cuartos una vez más por
qué es esto útil porque ahora cinco
cuartos es mayor que dos cuartos cuánto
es cinco cuartos menos dos cuartos bueno
eso será tres cuartos
y cuánto estrés -2 bueno eso será 1 así
que obtenemos como resultado un entero y
tres cuartos otra forma de resolverlo es
primero restar 42 y después sumar un
cuarto menos dos cuartos de nuevo
tenemos un pequeño problema con un
cuarto menos dos cuartos era el mismo
problema que teníamos por aquí pero para
resolverlo tomamos algo del valor de
cuatro en lugar de cuatro podemos
reescribirlo como tres enteros más
cuatro cuartos esto es lo mismo que
cuatro y no olvidemos a esto quitarle
dos más un cuarto menos dos cuartos
después si sumamos cuatro cuartos al un
cuarto obtenemos cinco cuartos
entonces nos quedará tres menos dos que
es esta parte y esta parte y después
tendremos que si sumamos cuatro cuartos
más un cuarto es más cinco cuartos menos
dos cuartos y es exactamente lo que
tenemos la derecha
tres enteros y cinco cuartos menos dos
enteros y menos dos cuartos
por último tres menos dos es uno y cinco
cuartos menos dos cuartos es tres
cuartos